Speaker 1: All right. I one of the I guess we
would call it a trend at this point that we've
seen for years as Donald Trump makes holidays,
tragedies and anniversaries somehow about himself
or about attacking his political opponents. Donald
Trump, it is Veteran's Day today. It is Veterans
Day today, and Donald Trump released a very
short video this morning. This is his tribute to
veterans on Veterans Day. Now, he sort of alludes
to criticizing Biden by saying Things are tough
and we're going to try to fix them. He doesn't
name Biden, but of course it's all alluding to.
It's just so bad under Joe Biden right now.
But also, like just every aspect of this is
weird. The framing is from really far away from
Trump, like he looks almost 20 feet away from
the camera. It's very strange. But the audio,
they don't even have a microphone on Trump.
Not even, I guess, caring enough about his
message to the troops, which was partially
just a criticism of the current state of affairs,
as Trump sees it. They didn't even put a mike
on Trump. It's just whatever Mike is on the
camera, like down to the technical details.
It's a very strange video. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 4: This Veterans Day, I like to pay
tribute to all of those incredible people, and you
are indeed incredible people who served so well
and so strong and so powerfully in the United
States armed forces. We love you. Our nation
respects you. The world respects you. And we will
come back. Our country has gone through a lot. The
last period of time has been very, very tough.
Speaker 1: So this is this is Trump's way of
criticizing Biden. I just I hope there's no like,
what else could he possibly mean there actually
Speaker 4: what you have to watch? But
our country will be back and we'll be back
stronger than ever. Happy Veterans Day.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Donald Trump has a
very long history of making tragedies,
holidays, anniversaries about himself
on 9-11. You might remember that Donald
Trump called into a local TV station
and said, Hey, you know, now that the World Trade
Center towers fell, I have the tallest building in
lower Manhattan. Remember this? Take a look.
Speaker 4: You have one of the landmark
buildings down in the financial district 40 Wall
Street. Did you have any damage or did you know
what's happened down there?
Speaker 5: Well, it was an amazing
phone call. I made 40 Wall Street actually was
the second tallest building in downtown Manhattan,
and it was actually before the
World Trade Center was the tallest.
And then when they built the World
Trade Center, it became known as
the second tallest, and now it's the tallest.
Speaker 1: That was a nice one, right? In 2011,
Donald Trump claimed that he predicted the 9-11
attacks. He didn't. In 2013, he memorialized 911
by sending his best wishes to the haters
and losers. You might remember that one.
And then, of course, many times Donald Trump
claimed to be at ground zero. He has said this
on 911 anniversaries past and just that other
speeches. Here is just one example of that.
Speaker 4: Soon after, I went down to ground zero
with men who worked for me to try to help in any
little way that we could. We were not alone.
Speaker 1: So that was a lie as well.
Donald Trump was not at ground zero any more than
maybe he was in an office that could generally be
considered to be in lower Manhattan around the
time of 911. This should not shock any of us.
This should not surprise any of us. This is what
Donald Trump does, and it's pathetic and it's
humiliating and embarrassing. So, OK, not going
to spend a lot of time on it. That's the latest.
What the former president has been
up to over the last couple of days